in 1914 an Archduke of Austria-Hungary
was shot by a Serbian nationalist this
led after a series of Nations signing
treaties with other nations to one of
the bloodiest conflicts ever fought a
war that was unlike any that had been
fought at the time trench combat mud and
sandbags newer deadlier advancements in
the art of warfare vile incurable and
fatal diseases and months upon months of
Misery all while trapped in dark dank
dugouts the Great War the first world
war it's gone by many names since its
ceasefire in 1918 and while there aren't
many left of the generation that
remembers it there are still plenty of
scars left on the world that remind us
of the horrors but there's one that
seems to be keeping those wounds fresh
reminding us that war is indeed hell
as that rough Beast slouches towards its
destination this is
scp-2574 what appears from the outset to
be nothing more than a stone sculpture
of a lion comprised of sandstone and
living tissue standing at around 12
meters tall
scp-2574 is much more than a mere statue
in fact it is a living creature after
all this is the SCP Foundation we're
talking about here where inanimate
objects are rarely inanimate at all or
will at least possess some form of
anomalous properties setting apart
anything ordinary and thus drawing the
interest of the foundation
scp-2574 is similar in that regard and
not just for being a living statue
creature for one the anomaly is capable
of movement albeit at a gradual rate
that only progresses between three and
five kilometers per day attempts by the
foundation to slow or halt the movement
of scp-25 74 have been so far
unsuccessful as it seems that any
obstacle placed in its path are unable
to deter it this includes both man-made
and naturally occurring obstructions
meaning there is little that can be
deployed to keep
scp-2574 physically contained even if a
body of water is in its path The Entity
can swim at a rate of between two and
three kilometers per day and will
normally either crush or climb over any
obstacle on land at the previous annual
budgeting meeting the top minds of the
foundation's accounting department
revealed to an infuriated o5 Council
that
scp-2574 had been responsible for an
estimated total of 25.3 million US
dollars in Damages since its Discovery
the second most pressing matter raised
during that presentation was that 112
deaths and a further 625 injuries the
anomaly had also caused despite I please
from the Ethics Committee the foundation
accountants were still adamant that the
cost of Damages was more significant now
a number of prevailing questions might
be plaguing you regarding
scp-2574 for one what does this creature
want if it has freedom of movement and
can't be physically obstructed by the
foundation then is it just aimlessly
wandering free and causing wonton
destruction or does it have a specific
want or goal it seeks to attain and for
another what does an almost 40-foot tall
lion have to do with World War One while
it might surprise you to know that
scp-2574 has everything to do with the
Great War literally everything and as
for a goal it has won or rather it has a
specific destination it seems to be
gradually heading towards and if it
makes it all the way there it could
spell disaster for the entire globe in
fact it could plunge us back into one of
the most devastating conflict the world
has ever seen can you guess which one
scp-2574 possesses a wide array of
latent anomalous effects Beyond its
General functionality and movement above
the Sandstone line creature it is
constantly surrounded by A Flock of
around 6 000 Birds of Prey any that find
themselves flying into the path of
scp-2574 are assimilated into the
growing flock designated as
scp-2574-1 the mass of birds is fixated
on attacking
scp-2574 swooping low to strike at its
smooth muscle tissue with using their
beaks and Talons this however seems to
do little to deter
scp-2574 from making progress as the
anomaly constantly regenerates from
physical damage it incurs from
scp-2574-1 perhaps the most notable and
noticeable of
scp-2574's anomalous properties is the
effect it has on its surroundings as it
progresses towards its destination the
area around
scp-2574 will undergo a physical
transformation in response to the
presence of the lion this transformation
results in the nearby region temporarily
becoming a World War One era combat zone
the ground below becomes riddled with
trenches carved through the Earth thick
muddy bogs and coiled razor-sharp Nets
of barbed wire litter the area the
change triggered by
scp-2574 is hardly just a cosmetic one
either the foundation have observed a
number of First World War related
manifestations that occur in the wake of
scp-2574 man-made land masses like
trenches and dugouts will appear nearby
the front lines reappearing after more
than a century Weaponry from the area is
also present following the arrival of
scp-2574 and this isn't just limited to
Firearms World War one was one of the
earliest large-scale conflicts in
history where in both sides deployed
aerial attacks through the use of
biplanes as well as chemical warfare as
a result signs of these can also be
found whenever
scp-2574 is nearby but again the
transformation
scp-2574 brings about is not just
limited to recreating battlefields what
some of you may not know is the Great
War did not so much revolve around a
core idealistic difference between both
sides as its successor did instead the
first world war was a geopolitical
grudge match between large Global
superpowers attempting to make grandiose
displays of their amassed military
strength the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand of Austria at the hands
of a Serbian extremist group was the
Catalyst that set off a chain reaction
of events that ultimately led to War as
a result of this
scp-2574's anomalous influence also
extends to the social and political
state of the areas it enters a country
that the Sandstone leonine entity enters
will suffer a rapid change in its local
population's mentality the ordinary
people living there will start to
experience a great degree of discontent
towards their government while the
ruling powers of said country will
increase its use of force against its
own civilians this effect is more
noticeably potent when
scp-2574 interacts with countries that
were directly involved in the first
world war increasing levels of civil
unrest and discontentment among the
population these are often countered
with worryingly increased levels of
police brutality along with governments
enacting aggressive foreign policies and
sometimes antagonizing other countries
as if they are eager to fight these
effects don't necessarily worsen the
closer
scp-2574 gets to a particular country
but do seem to increase the more it
approaches its predicted destination and
where is that you may ask the foundation
have calculated that based on
scp-2574's trajectory since its
emergence back in 2012. the entity is
headed for the city of Sarajevo the
capital city of Bosnia and Herzegovina
what possible reason could
scp-2574 have for wanting to venture
towards this specific Bosnian City well
one cursory glance at the history of
Sarajevo will give you the answer it's
where the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand took place the event
commonly attributed with starting the
first world war the transformative
effects
scp-2574 has on its surroundings began
when the leonine Leviathan first
appeared and commenced its Journey
towards Sarajevo on December 24 2012.
since then the SCP Foundation has been
closely monitoring the Sandstone
creatures movements and attempting to
log all of the anomalous effects it has
had over the course of making its way
closer to the site of Franz ferdinand's
assassination over 5000 kilometers away
to the east of kazakhstan's capital
Astana
scp-2574 caused an unusual World War One
anomalous effect any written works
published in either Russian or Kazakh
began to randomly feature passages from
Irish poet W.B Yates these extracts from
his body of work range from single
sentences to entire poems being featured
in other writers Publications regardless
of author or genre Yates for anyone
unfamiliar was widely considered one of
the greatest Poets of the 20th century
however unlike the authors of numerous
poems and songs to come out of the first
world war W.B Yates was never directly
involved in the conflict itself and
didn't write much about it barring a few
notable exceptions but more on him in a
moment when
scp-2574 approached Russia things
started to escalate
clouds of deadly chlorine gas an early
World War one chemical weapon began
forming in rural areas throughout Europe
that couldn't be dispersed for days at a
time as soon as the Towering anomaly got
close enough Russian military forces
began launching a series of drone
strikes and aerial bombardments
targeting
scp-2574 when these attacks failed
tensions mounted with bordering
countries the situation only getting
worse when it was discovered through an
intelligence leak that Russia was
planning a nuclear strike against the
creature a move that likely could have
spelled disaster for the neighboring
countries
scp-2574 of course sustained no damage
and continued on its course given that
they couldn't physically contain
scp-2574 the foundation was forced to
think outside of the box when it came to
coming up with some kind of solution
there were already too many eyewitnesses
aware of the leonine leviathan's
existence to consider administering
amnestics even on a large scale the fact
was too many people already knew about
scp-2574 and would make such a move
pointless the best that the foundation
could do to combat if not counteract the
effects of
scp-2574 was to work directly with
governments affected by the creatures
World War One transformative effects to
try and repair the damage left in the
anomalies wake and ease the tension and
violence it caused it became the
foundation's job to deter any country
planning and armed military response to
the presence of
scp-2574 as any such strike would
endanger both their military and
civilian populations while causing no
damage to the anomaly in the interest of
trying to solve the problems posed by
scp-2574 reverting parts of Europe to
hellish First World War era battlefields
the foundation made a rare agreement to
collaborate with another large
organization specializing in in the
anomalous the global occult Coalition
working directly with the GOC their goal
was to create a large-scale memetic
countermeasure that would effectively
reset the toll
scp-2574 had exacted on global
Psychology by altering people's
temperaments and creating mass political
unrest as it progressed towards the
Bosnian Capital however given the tense
history between the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition their
attempts at creating a memetic
countermeasure are still ongoing since
neither group wants the other to engage
them in full-scale mimetic Warfare as
such the proposed countermeasure will
consist of two parts with neither
organization being able to replicate the
other's half meanwhile
scp-2574's progress across Europe was
responsible for a number of other
significant changes physically socially
and politically recreating the
conditions of the first world war
poppies a flower that is since become
synonymous with the remembrance of the
conflict began to grow in regions within
Russia where they wouldn't naturally
occur this included within Urban
locations the red flowers sprouting in
and around buildings as a result of such
a high profile anomaly causing such
widespread unrest to spread a number of
religious cults centered around
scp-2574 began to form while the living
descendants of World War One veterans
began suffering from Vivid
hallucinations that depicted their
ancestors first-hand experience of the
fighting these Cults began to amass more
and more of those affected by
scp-2574 the SCP Foundation was able to
observe some of the sermons delivered by
these religious cults who appeared to
view the public appearances of
scp-2574 as signs of an impending
apocalypse come to us and embrace your
salvation one cult leader exclaimed in a
sermon discover the words of the Prophet
Yates who spoke this sacred truth that
all of history is a spiral and that we
have spiraled outwards towards chaos
land the true nature of the second
coming it appeared that some of these
Cults viewed the Poetry of WB Yates as
prophetic in regards to
scp-2574 they would often reference the
second coming which interestingly was
the name of one of his poems written in
the aftermath of World War One Yates is
the second coming refers to a rough
Beast slouching towards Bethlehem the
SCP Foundation has since uncovered some
erratic writings made by the poet before
his death that allude to Bethlehem
despite no record existing of him ever
traveling there it is believed that
Yates somehow figured out what
scp-2574 was and that The Closer it gets
to its destination the more first
civilization will spiral further out of
control towards total all-consuming
chaos further research by the foundation
also uncovered a testimony made by
gavrilo princip the Serbian man
responsible for assassinating Archduke
Franz Ferdinand of Austria and thus
sparking the first world war princeip
seems to have had some knowledge about
scp-2574 and apparently killed the
Archduke as a way to begin the
creature's journey in order to make
Society more chaotic with
scp-2574 progressing worryingly closer
to the site of Franz ferdinand's
assassination further chaos rapidly
began to spread anarchic sentiments took
hold of most of Europe leading to an
increased rate of violent encounters
between civilians and police in many
countries including Ireland France Great
Britain and Italy with a number of these
experiencing widespread rioting in their
major population centers any government
or political party come compelled by
scp-2574 to openly espouse the same
Anarchist sentiments we're soon seeing a
rapid increase in their public approval
getting more popularity in polls than
their opposition as a result of these
heightened tensions between the public
and the government of their countries
assassination attempts of politicians
saw an alarming increase of around 60
percent
scp-2574 caused countries that have
existing hostile relations to engage in
armed skirmishes at their borders with
at least one of these battles occurring
every two weeks and each time
threatening to spark a much larger scale
conflict thanks to the anomaly's effects
the international tensions dissolving
alliances between countries and Adoption
of nationalism which were all factors
leading to the start of the Great War
were beginning to rapidly spread once
again by the time
scp-2574 was around 550 kilometers from
Sarajevo people began experiencing
injuries common among soldiers during
World War One many patients would die
during surgery only for their bodies to
disappear shortly afterwards conflict
erupted between Ireland and England it
has scp-2574 entered Bosnia and
Herzegovina many began to report
suffering intense dreams about the
anomaly a number of these reports seemed
to state that
scp-2574 was attempting to communicate
with them and multiple websites begin
logging the Sandstone Lions appearance
in their dreams and things will only get
worse the closer
scp-2574 gets to Sarajevo
scp-2574 contains the raw energy of
world war one one of the most
catastrophic events in human history a
global conflict with a death toll in the
tens of millions the SCP Foundation
estimates it'll reach the site of Franz
ferdinand's assassination within a month
and from that point given the effect
it's had on the rest of Europe there's
only one likely outcome when that rough
bee slouches towards its ultimate
destination War now check out scp-186 to
end all wars and World War II German
scps explain for more